you wonder num broadcasting hi this is
Fred eh I'm your lecturer for today like
you to read this
CME continuing education disclosure and
at the end of the talk or during the
talk you can post some questions in the
question and answer write them down and
I'll try to get to most of them as we go
along or at the end of the talk I'll put
some timely to answering some of your
questions ok so you've read all that
I'll move on to my first slide of the
presentation which is gives the title
function and regulation of adult
neurogenesis and all these pick me today
the whole idea the donor genesis came
somewhat of a surprise for people to
critical issues here one is that the
cells were dividing all the time in the
brain we have no consistency wouldn't be
able to keep them memory and the other
is who we are as person the second
really was that how could a neuron
actually undergo cell division is such a
complex structure so and know that these
neurons here I'm going to use my tool to
point out you see how neurons are really
complex structures you have branches the
idea that the silicon are going to go
was unusual and we have 10 billion
neurons in the brain and hundreds of
thousands of connections so the idea
that this was resolved by the fact that
two things one is that neurogenesis of
the birth of new neurons did not occur
in every year in the brain but
restricted to just a few areas of the
brain so the whole brain wasn't turning
over all the time and the other point is
that cells really didn't divide your
arms didn't divide but in fact there are
stem cells and mature cells exist in the
brain and those are the ones that gave
rise to the absolutely new neurons so
those who are with those new facts
coming along we were able to accommodate
these concepts
there's too many instead of the
mammalian brain where neurogenesis
occurs one is in the lateral ventricle
region right here and the cells are born
in this area here then migrate along
this pathway here where they reach the
olfactory bulb and once they get a ride
Neil factory bulb they passed through
the grandness a layer or giving rise to
stem cells here but also periodically
giving rise to neurons but by passing
these micro areas in there I'm just
learning how to do this pointer so bear
with me here the other area in the brain
where this occurs is a structure called
campus and the campus is the structure
that is involved in learning a memory
and the cells are born right in here
it's called a sub granular zone and this
is what is themselves proliferate and
then migrate and eventually
differentiate not going to this one more
detail so this is a real picture not a
cartoon
shows the area specifically of the
dentate gyrus where these new neurons
are being born they're represented by
these green cells and I'll tell you how
they are labeled all the cells in the
dentate are for the most part excitatory
neurons inside here we have and
interestingly the cells that are for any
use of internal turn I'm going to
olfactory bulb they're inhibitory so
there really is a difference in the
faint at least of the stem cells that
are in these two different areas so in a
more detail about Anatomy here's the
whole of the campus again here's our
dentate gyrus this is called the c3 is
where the fibers from the dentate
project and seeing one is where c3 then
projects and the inner zone between the
two deletion of the dentate gyrus called
Hylas we'll go into more detail and this
molecular layer here is where the
branches from the Granville cells move
into so this is what we call a niche
here's the dentate to get you oriented
again these are the stem cells they're
surrounded by blood vessels and
astrocytes keeping these stem cells
nourished they have to move away from
that niche in a few days to get rise to
their neurons with branches well it
takes about a month to six days before
the immature cell is is fully mature
more like six to eight weeks here's the
whole structure now giving us an idea of
the dentate granule nods with the inner
cells here being hollow cells inhibitory
neurons that are suppressing the
activity of these an excitatory neurons
these new materials sending their
processes out to sea a3 the ca3 then
going to the ca1 and then back out again
to the internal cortex it's the internal
cortex each tune that gives us these
cells here that then go all the way to
the
granule neurons they go from here to
there there to there and then back out
again so that's the synaptic circuit
can't this how information is processed
and the memories are formed so here's a
diagram again and what you see here is
that there is inches here this is where
the cells are born and here we can see
down here that there are various
transmitters that regularly the fate of
the cells at various stages so we have
progenitor cells progenitor cells that
go to differentiated cells all mature
cells let me see that GABA is
controlling at various stages of this
process from from stem cells on down
glutamate acetylcholine are more
involved in the process of maturation
and the M energic system is controlling
them at earlier stages of
differentiation you should also talk
about this give you some details about
this Wow but the rate that neurogenesis
occurs and the number of cells that are
born is influenced by activity so
physical exercise like running and
increase neurogenesis an enrichment can
support survival so you end up with more
new cells while our stress is a negative
regulator and decreases in our local
operating cells again the circuitry
showing this inputs from the internal
cortex again to get to the communal
cortex to
yeah
from Iranian cortex the dentate didn't
take to see a tree seed one and then
back out again now we know the more
detail about the timing of this we think
that there are these very primitive
cells that are non-dividing for the most
part they can give rise to a rapidly
dividing so that's after this division
occurs this initial invasion occurs
things about seven days for the first
processes to get out and then they don't
get their inputs till later I'll be
repeating this with various examples
over time one thing it's clear as we now
know a lot about the molecular markers
that identify the cells at various
stages so the quiescent mostly quiet
stem cells are if you think he positive
sucks to positive intestine positive
whereas the proliferating population of
cells or socks to positive nest and
positive and TLX positive but they're
not G FA p+ these these cells here
stem cells sorry these are the whites
and stem cells he's rapidly dividing
cells and these are the neurons neurons
in the campus express variety markers
that identified them as being mature in
particular aprox 1 and a new variety
ways to mark these cells as being newly
born we use a world nucleic acid
analogue called grow deoxy urging their
substitutes for your genome the cells
undergoing cell division so he
incorporates into the DNA after a single
injection so all these black dots
respond to them in born cells in other
cases we use transgenic animals that
Express markers of the cells at varying
stages in addition we use retroviruses
retroviruses our viruses that can be
modified to the non-toxic that express a
gene like GFP that can mark the cell
that undergo cell division and the cells
stay mark the advantage here is it fills
up the cytoplasm so here's an example of
the fact that me can see this
neurogenesis now in every million
organism that has been identified so far
so from the mouse to human and in the
dentate itself was very much the same in
all these structures they all have a
coxswain making this human study back in
1998 visions of cancer were administered
after your game to see how fast their
tumor was growing and subsequently when
their brains were examine it was shown
that there was an incorporation into
stem cells that became neurons and
survived for years and their brains
evidencing for the first time that there
is adult neurogenesis in humans this was
subsequently confirmed years later many
years later the Swedish study by
Spalding Andreessen showing more
quantitatively than
up to 800 new neurons are being born
human campus on a daily basis so here's
what some of these retroviral injections
look like and how they function this is
a retrovirus has three components the
virus itself with core proteins and a
pseudo envelope that allows it to infect
mammalian cells easily stereotypes we
inject this this virus into the brain
where it is any weights into just those
cells they're undergoing cell division
within the within the structure here and
the advantage of it is that it fills up
the cell cytoplasm not just the nucleus
so here are three days you can see the
cells that just infected and they're
very immature
not many processes by seven days they
have already begun to show processes and
then by 10 days you have long processes
going up here and by 14 days they
branched and then by 21 days it's even
further branching and importantly here
we go only up to 14 months after the
initial injection the cells are 5 and
are fully integrated into the circuit
here's the study asking the nature of
these cells so can we use one of these
markers like socks to which identifies
the stem cells and be certain that they
really are coming from the socks to
positive cell so we've used a variety of
molecular trick techniques the tutors
you only have transgenic Mouse
expressing socks to off the gfa
expression GFP of the substitute
promoter and you can see here that this
the brain is its GFP positive if we now
look inside the brain we can see that
the dentate gyrus is gfp positive so it
seems you've worked our socks to
positive cells are there we need to
confirm this and what I'm sorry so you
can see that when we double label B some
of our other markers we have soft to
positive cells with long processes
likely the immature radial cells and
also we have some of these small amount
of radial cells as there as well so
socks - was labeling both the Quietus
and so as well as the Richer so the
advantage of this mouse is that we can
actually sort for GFP and pull down this
fraction of primitive cells that exist
in there about 6% of the total
population and in T cells they can be
propagated in culture your socks -
positive nested positive GFP positive
beside negative negative as I show you
that the proliferating cells are gaap
negative whereas the quiet ones are
typically positive so here were
liberating the we call type tool or the
pool if reading themselves these cells
then can be induced to differentiate
into neurons to uj1 positive double
cordon as well as all of your vendor
sites and energy a few closes evidencing
the fact that these really are stem
cells as they can be isolated propagated
into different cell types now to do fake
marking what we've done is to take
monkey bars that has a Sox tuning
promoter driving GFP slash cream and we
inject that into a flock stops flux
negative Mouse so when we knock out that
flocks with the cream then we get
recombination event occurring and the
cells turn green so we can mark cells
permanently that had been socks - at the
time of the injection
didn't make impulse would be Arnie you
and father sells at various time points
later to see what not that sorry what
the fate of that sucks to positive cell
was and when we do that you can see that
here's the socks to positive cell it was
at one point and some twenty eight days
later it had undergone cell divisions
these ones and it still sucks too that
means some of the stem cells are
dividing and became separating or some
others I can give rise to neuron so
here's a sucks to infected cell so the
water sucks to under division BR new
label and now it's double cordon
positive and here's another one this Cox
one so they have capacity for giving
rise to multiple images and here's the
gif a pea pod this is rare they don't
give rise to gif ap sucks - I'm sorry in
GFP sucks 100 cells very often usually
they give advice to neurons so the
conclusion here is we think that this
living cell is the one that gives rise
to neurons and glial cells and there is
some evidence that this can also be
differentiate into the kawaii as himself
we think of these as the initial cell
but they are not giving rise directly to
neurons but rather it looks like they're
given rise this intermediate stem cell
then give rise to the other cell types
okay so let's look at what role the
local environment might play is there
something unique about these cells
interestingly when we post an animal
increment great throw many up to your
name you can find the rd labeled cells
all over the bringing in the cortex and
certainly the subgrade is known but also
you know the white matter so why don't
we get nerves in other places so what we
can do is we could isolate these stem
cells directly from the brain and inject
them into either a neurogenic region or
a non dimensional region so here we've
taken stem cells directly from the brain
and injected them into the pecans and
they can give rise to mature when we
inject hippocampal neurons into the
olfactory bulb they can go only that the
effective bald area in your eyes to
olfactory you're not suggesting that
these cells can behave according to the
environment that they're in so they're
not restricted in terms of their
capacity if we inject them into the
spinal cord what we do we see that they
they don't give rise to no - Krishna
there are no stem cells give rise to
neurons there but if they do survive
migrating here belies the kalila cells
so what is it about the environment
that's so important for giving rise to
neurons exclusively in the olfactory
bulb in the campus there's animosity
image of the dentate gyrus and you can
see that there's this blood vessel and
these cells are in the cusp of light
vessels so they're getting some sort of
nutriment from the blood vessels that
seem to me one of the important features
of of this this is actually more power
showing that labeled cells GFP green
neurons here you can see the highly rich
that's your nature of this
doesn't seem to be an important feature
of this in addition to blood vessels
astrocytes are important so here we're
labeling with the are you and with GF ap
and they find that they're surrounded by
blood vessels and with astrocytes
forming this need for the cells so main
let's see if there's something important
about the astrocytes when we take these
cells out of the brain and as cultured
and plate them on hippocampal astrocytes
they will spontaneously differentiate
into neuron suggesting astrocytes are
making something that allows them to
differentiate if I would put them on
astrocytes from spinal cords they don't
differentiate so already we know that
there's something unique in the
environment that allows them to
differentiate that's fine astrocytes so
we've gone in to dissect out what was
unique about these extra sites in the
two regions of the brain we find it in
in the spinal cord I started with big
campus astrocytes they contained all
major pathways singly so the receptor is
all the way down through the TCF lot of
wishes that I can a binding domain for
the canonical my signal with the are
missing these are the neural progenitor
cells have all the signaling pathways so
they can be affected by like what they
don't have is any other factors
themselves the ligands but when we look
into the exercise we see that they are
in fact contained with activity and when
the test for the effect of blocking when
signal we can show that we can decrease
the amount of neurons that are they made
so when it seems to be in vitro crucial
factor in taking themselves from an
undifferentiated state into a
differentiated state we prove this very
convincingly by using a dominant
negative wind so that's a block light
signaling and inject that into the
hippocampus where
the monkey buyers with blocks with
signaling and then we look for a marker
of
their Genesis between you double court
here's the controlled wires you can see
the red it's all double court and the
cells are flying with the control virus
but it blocks neurogenesis and then
negative Mickey virus this is the
complication of that so what more do we
know about this we know that narudy is a
transcription factor that's really
important in the transition from a stem
cell to a neuron us or the middle stage
and when signaling appears to be a an
activator of marady in fact within the
promoter of nerdy there are a number of
these beta team and GCS not binding
sites and is truly believe it's through
this direct application activation of
this promoter that the economic system
turns on the mural differentiation
program these are some studies showing
that when you block your OD in vitro you
can block the differentiation of cells
into neurons and this docks regulated
controlled 19 cells here in vivo in a
study was published by another group
showed that when you knock your idea
entirely in this group here we did a
complete loss of the dentate gyrus
showing the nerdy is obligatory for the
formation so when you get in a more
general way to think that when signaling
at early stages is important
proliferation of the cells but then it
activates a past
initial cascade that induces the cells
differentiate so it's a crucial factor
through its activation of directing
interestingly the canonical wind
signaling pathway decreases
as the sales beef differentiate and the
non-canonical pathway plays a role in
the carbonization story today we'll be
able to get to today but was recently
published numerous neuroscience so we've
got a an interesting conundrum here
we've got a new bunch of cells coming in
know that they're receiving
well they potentially can receive inputs
from either on your cortex and then send
out axons to the c3 and also get
interactions with these hyper cells
question is in the adult brain aren't
they actually integrating fully into
this into the system here is a cartoon
this is actually a real picture of a GFP
fox gfa p+ juice our GFP labeled newly
born neuron and solutions are called
spines lines come in different flavors
they have these Phillip rhodium very
young begin to mature they become steady
in them they're little larger than the
Heavy's large mushroom audience from
their non-mobile
and quite mature so we can quantify
these in vivo and in vitro itself don't
have any spines when they're 14 days but
by 21 days they have a lot become very
dense responds later a finer dissection
shows that it's really the transition
between a 15 and 16 that they get
supplies my 17 year on so this is timing
of spine development is very specific I
mean I wanted to look very specifically
whether or not the environment for
chicks
which is the input from the cortex TV
screen themselves make contact so here's
a green
GFP positive cell here
and we use a red virus in the internal
cortex which is a linking virus and it
tracks the excellences they go through
the neural cortex to be to the dendrites
of these cells red up here and here you
can see in red presynaptic terminal on a
green post net terminal suggesting that
the neural cortex actually makes direct
contact with and here we're taking this
to the electron microscopic level so we
get photo bleaching of this green
fluorescent dye so the cells turn black
the processes turned here's a spine in
every one cell making contact with the
presynaptic terminal there's all these
nice little vesicles these vesicles in
there you see here's their person at the
presynaptic side in addition on the
other side so these are the axons that
are coming out of the these are the
axons coming out from the mossy fibers
growing up to ca3 region here we look at
this higher power you can see that there
are in fact mostly fiber big mostly
fiber terminals from a newly born cell
making contact on the dendrites and on
the shafts of the existing ca3 domes
so all we can see now that newly born
cells make contact both with their new
the more cells make contact with the
inputs coming in from your neural cortex
on their spines and the newly warm
mostly copper terminals to make contact
with their partners on the ca3 region
right here you look at the time course
of this and what looks like happening is
that there's a temporal nature the
Phillip Odia form first and then later
on we get mature and mossy fiber
terminals and it looks very much like
there's some sort of competition that's
going on we hypothesize that these these
fine processes here for liquidity here
compete with the existing senses and
they get larger once they get there
and finally they compete out and where
this one's now lost and the sole new one
takes its place
competition and we see the same thing
happening in the exons inputs music time
course this process of a so we have both
a presynaptic and postsynaptic
competition so there's no we don't think
there's actually new synapses being
formed to me but rather the formation of
competition of a pre-existing synapses
that constitute this process here's a
cartoon of that so you have a previous
image here's the new Tripodi coming in
over time they had this direct
competition and one runs out there are a
bunch of theories and other people are
testing this hypothesis right now one
suggestion is that the astrocytes which
were not depicted in here are playing
some key role in regulating this
but it remains to be seen
this is on the presynaptic side the new
terminals coming in from the movie for
themselves are competing for this spy
existing synapse so we know now that
they make anatomical connections the
question is are they physiologically the
first evidence for physiological and
electrophysiological activity these
newly forming cells came in 2002 2004
interesting paper showed that the young
cells when they're moving in have a
different activity there they seem to be
hyper excitable and this was confirmed
later on so what what is this
hyperexcitability all about so I want
you to look at here are some
electrophysiological tracings that show
that the immature cells so here we'll
look at one month one month of age in
the new so the cells are one month of
age and immature neuron and this regular
LTP like response is close a longer term
or hyper excitable LTP whereas immature
cells we have an LTP but it's much lower
level so this is the hyperexcitability
has been reported by many investigators
of the young cells that seems to go away
so people wanted to know what this
hyperexcitability really is all about it
does show that the four-week-old animals
have this hyperexcitability from
baseline whereas the eight-week-old
don't have it in the presence if you
don't block in addition gaba so there's
so much gaba normally you miss slice
these things if you block gaba
you you can see the hyperexcitability
but interestingly young animals it
doesn't matter if you brought gaba or
not they're hyper excitable that gives
you a hint of what I'm going to tell you
about in a minute and that is that the
so distorted a little bit but that
here's this hyperexcitability in young
cells and if we give gaba we can
suppress that however in the old cells
we have to block gap in order to be able
to see the elevated amount of LTP so if
you have explained two different roles
in the young versus the old cells so
what's the source of the in addition
that we see actually here's this campus
again we've got a lot of inputs I told
you that these transmitter systems could
regulate neurogenesis and they also have
excellence into this area but what is
the source of the gaba that we've seen
we use the technique called
rabies virus tracing your little tracy
mcgrady started reading letters
naturally propagates between neurons in
a retrograde manner and colleagues here
at the swamp join young and weaker Shaun
in Callaway's lab developed this as a
technique to convenience or trace of
neurons and they use a modified rabies
virus which is normally toxic so they
jump across more than one synapse that's
restricted to only label cells that are
connected to them - like mono synaptic
connectivity and I'll show you an
example of this here we have the model
that we used and this is based
transgenic animal by lincoln floor stand
which has a flux top which normally
prevents the rabies lipoprotein from
being expressed and if you use a Kree
retrovirus which is only been labeled
with dividing cells remember we can flux
this out and express this TBA so now we
can come back at a later time point with
Wiress the rabies virus which has a
deleted glycoprotein and ejected and
whenever we want and see who's connected
to the newly born self right at that
very moment so it's a very effective way
of selectively labeling just a newborn
cells and this was that some more yours
just showing that it work she proceeded
in yellow or the double labeled cells of
a are the cells that were originally
labeled in the red ones without the
yellow of the cells that are connected
to those cells so this is all within the
dentate so there's a lot of connections
right there nearby
but if we look distal to it here we are
in Iran cortex maybe that's layer two so
those are the cells that connect to that
really bore themselves and this is
showing that they're connected through
validation of technique works
interestingly in the medial septal area
we're getting nice connections : your
cheek and GABAergic neurons that are in
the medial septal area that project into
new b1 cells and we see in the mid brain
cells that are as expected we see cells
in the Hylas these are these large
Highland mossy cells these are in fact
excitatory
as well as inhibitory neurons in meeting
connections we have a little bit of
surprise in a molecular layer so this is
where the dendrites are we found these
large cells that had been identified by
Thomas point and need a new jockey some
years ago molecular called mob cells and
they are also connected to the unit
point cells this is single cell this is
almost in critical axonal processes
sound as an inhibitory cell also has a
control from this region when we record
from these cells we see that they are in
fact inhibitory cells in this lens so
the theory and we think how this works
is when a stimulus comes in from the
environment cortex we have some direct
input to the granule cells but there's
also a feed-forward in addition here
there's some missing a line go through
these inhibitory neurons to shut
ourselves off and you can see the timing
of this so this is a excitatory
postsynaptic terminal epsp with short
duration that would be the direct this
would be the direct connection from the
neuronal cortex here and then you have
this one here with the delay and that is
because you're recording from here and
you're going through the inventory notes
before you get there so you have a delay
so the first is an excitation followed
by an inhibition making the regulating
as the duration of the response so here
we have potential for a feed-forward and
a vision mechanism from the molecular
layer feeding medium this maturation
dependent in addition at the midpoint
and here just gives you a summary of
these lop cells that are they're called
and molecular layer the trainer and we
identified and that the brain is also
received from both of these locations so
the conclusion is that cortical and
subcortical local dilatory inputs are
identified by genetic rabies Jenica
irises even babies during maturation
mobile inhibitory inputs through our
neurons are gradually increasing it
become excitatory this is during all the
critical period this developmental
change in in addition has a dual role it
can increase societies that they are
able to respond to environment in an
exaggerated way but it also acts to the
timer because they may turn down and
become more over time so let's talk
about another feature that I mentioned
to you before about different
environment events that affect your
genesis we have enrichment exercises I
mentioned can increase your chances in
terms of learning it's negative things
like epilepsy stroke increase
neurogenesis they increase neurogenesis
but cells that are for more aberrant
there's also a lot of things that
decrease neurogenesis genetic changes
stress aging very smart and models and
actually in the clinical tissue for 18
diabetes intimate issues
this is the example of attrition
environments so here's an almost normal
housing enrichment and you can see here
very dramatically that there's an
alliteration there cells in the money
pages and this increase in writing can
an enrichment here for example can
result in forty five to fifty thousand
in neurons over 30 to 45 days and the
ball unit entry increases so this is a
highly regulated phenomenon experiencing
regularly here's a here's a picture of
the mouse on the money this is actually
manufacturing picture that they usually
running running also have these super
close to four little humor but the truth
is that there's this is the distance and
this is not granule itself and there's a
good correlation treaty - interestingly
there's a decrease in neurogenesis with
aging dramatic ears that six months
versus 21 months in a rat decreases we
asked whether or not old animals
increases neurogenesis could be
activated by mining today i'm mr.kidding
brdu and Brandon O'Neil and they were
tested in water near nineteen months of
age what we see is that the old runners
in a sedentary situation had a lot of
hard time finding the means deciding and
this is documented here showing that the
aged animals that
the ancient animals that had writing
experience and this is these guys here
in the circles they performed latency
nearly as well as Nino controls so not
only are we seeing an increase in their
Genesis what we're seeing a an increase
in performance in these here's their
quantitation on the performance this is
the young animals that are running it
over the world here's the young animals
and what we get is a significant
increase in the performance of all the
animals that had some money experience
in there if we look at atomically in old
and yummy materials a decrease but there
is a significant increase so here's the
old guys the label be are you winning
can bring them up to the level you know
that we're not running it doesn't bring
them up to running but it does increase
and if we look at their GFP labeling
from retroviruses these cells that are
born in the old soul bring our maturity
of spines and they look so if you can
get a new cell to be born it's good so
now we learn at the final stage to try
understand if these are functionally
significant what all these new neurons
they play and there's been a lot of
study he's trying to figure this out
most summarize a few of them and they're
based on a series of computational
models that have tried to map out the
possible role that the dentate may play
in a function that we know of as canvas
that we know that the canvas plays the
model was based on the more recent
movement based on an older model by
David Marr who suggested based on the
density of in Tate where they have so
many neurons compared to their input
in our cortex that it was a great
location for what's called sparse
vacation and when he later described as
pattern separation so keeping memories
distinct is one of the functions in the
dentate the process is taking complex
memories and converting images
representations that are less easily
confused in this process is known as
pattern separation the model goes on to
say that the particularly the new
neurons are involved and have an
integration where the mature neurons are
involved in pattern separation that the
timing of this neurons least typical
dynamics we can have calendar type
memory and some specialization of these
cells Wednesday so here's a practical
example when you park your car and the
location beginning today you come out in
the day it's a big parking lot you're
not parking the same place each time you
have to recall what you did that morning
and separate that from the other
mornings that you come out that's a
separation here's an animal version of
it this is an eight-armed maze and these
red bars respond to the these red bars
here correspond to the house separate
the bars are so the animals put into the
maze at this point and then they have
wounded into the maze on one trial they
go down and get food and then on the
second trial they have to remember to go
to the other and they're taken out and
put back in time and some of them are
very different from each other and some
are pretty close and what's clear is
that when you knock out neurogenesis jam
animals have a pretty high rate of
learning this at this low rates low
separation but you knock out American
assets and they have a much harder time
when you're very separate from each
other both blue stroke
this will come
here's another task where an animal has
to press a bar press their nose against
these windows here when they're
separated far apart like this it's high
separation it's easy for the animal to
make the discrimination between they
seeing the seeing here here the first
time and here the second time versus
when they close together it's harder to
make that distinction and curious
showing that again on this second task
that if you knock out neurogenesis they
have taken many more trials to criteria
than to the Sham animals but when it's
very easy to discriminate and we have
been proud we want to show that if you
run the animals and let them run their
running we know that you actually
enhance their ability to make
discrimination and small differences so
both knocking down and over pressing
neurogenesis has a reciprocal effect on
this type of pattern separation is been
tested in humans too and with a very
very similar result there's a paper by
Craig stark and science in 2008 so a lot
of people have published work on this
idea of neurogenesis and pattern
separation and all coming up with pretty
much the same conclusion so we're going
to so do let's test this a little bit
let me show you one more test here and
here we have a a an example of a mouse
that has a nest and driving TK the time
you can kinda needs then you give gen
cyclope R to these cells that are
dividing and they'll die so it's a
selective way of knocking out just the
dividing cells
or bring in cells their nest in positive
way to look wise that fact and when you
do that you can show that that's a
repeated Testament in cyclic you not got
about 50% of these it comes back in time
so if you stop giving the drug them you
know pick up again so here we are so
this is a test we've done to look for
that separation in another sense and
then you wait for a period of time and
exposure to that box or to a slightly
different box and so here's the pattern
separation they're very similar boxes
and what happens in normal animals can
make this discrimination though it's a
little tough for them they normally
freeze 40 50 seconds and they're showing
your ladybugs they they can tell the
difference statistically but it's tough
if you knock out neurogenesis they can't
tell them all if you wait nine weeks it
comes back again so they can they can
actually recover neurogenesis recover
their ability to make these apparent
separations this is just to show that in
fact it's saying in effect that is
dependent upon it being a closely
related box it's a very different box so
this this year would be the very
different from this box then we had no
trouble even without a very Genesis the
neurogenesis really is important only
for discriminating between closely
related objects so four-week-old
hyperexcitability neurons are not mature
neurons and are required for pattern
separation the neurons are only required
to disagree
in small differences between practice
and let's get this and come to the
conclusion and say here that the brain
is the organ control behavior neurons
continually made throughout life you've
really been making neurons is dependent
on behavior in experience we've learned
about running and exercise and the
depend on those kinds of things
your behavior can just affect the
structure the brain which controls
behavior thus learning music
instrumented we're deeply experienced a
new event can activate in neurons and
this could appreciate this could help
appreciate the finer details that exist
in life so last 20 years a lot of
progress in adult neurogenesis much more
you learn of mechanisms and new
technologies are needed to visualize and
see needs in the future so stop hearing
thank you for your questions the go over
here to the Q&A part and what are your
articles you've written that new
important rooms are different we act
differently than old ones newborn
neurons fires up at anything I'd like to
know that that case how the memory is
stored or replaced in that case
so they are different should I just try
to respond to that question the new
neurons neurons do respond differently
the new neurons when you're four weig
olds they're hyper excitable they have a
lower threshold for firing they have
less inhibition and the old ones are
highly limited and sparsely respond like
to know that in that case how so we
don't really know what the source of the
in gram is or how information is stored
within a particular cell but the idea is
that that excitable moment hyper excited
the Lord makes some change in that cell
that once it's mature its maintained and
that is a wonderful question of how its
information stored within the brain
within a cell I think it has there's
probably some molecular event that
occurred I see so anyway does a link
from experience to the innate immune
system and the creation will affected
receptors extend into the creation of
ignorance that's a great question
there is a significant amount of
evidence now suggesting that the immune
system is regulating to some extent
neurogenesis in particular in the
endogenous immune system is it's
reflected in the microglia within the in
the brain and those mic media are
definitely involved in regulating adult
neurogenesis now whether or not that
involved in the olfactory receptor gene
creation I'm not sure about that I know
mostly done that but I would not be
surprised sucks - cells can
differentiate into all injuries as well
right they can but in vivo they rarely
do different change into all the danger
sites you don't see all the new site
differentiation in vivo very often in
vitro enforced
conditions to make them old in inter
sites but not not in vivo let's see yes
further shown an ASCII such an
expression caused in neural stem so
different you know finish sites so at
the time to warm to August all your
dinner plates to for my landing neurons
it's true it's true that refers back to
the previous question by the same person
I see ok yeah so if you force ASCII or
mash one in your neurons you can you can
get them to express it but that's a it
depends on the to the concentration that
your you're using normally it doesn't
occur but you can force it that's a good
point thanks for reminding me professor
if newly born neurons if you leap or
neurons compete from pre to post
synapses does this mean that older cells
have a pitocin
you know you have to think about this at
the Senate just every every newer ones
got thousands and thousands and 5,000
expected five thousand synapses on each
granule neuron so the competition is
just at that individual level so gaining
them using a few synapses may not result
in death on the other hand if you do
mean if a cell loses enough synapse that
will occur with it and we do see some
advertisers economy with age but it's
not it's not a dominant feature it's not
dummies regulatable one hello
would it be possible for you to post a
list of papers that you referenced
through this lecture in future well
certainly look into that shame to your
point there is a review written several
reviews about this and one of them in
physiological reviews and the 2014 is a
good summary of them very very long
chapter with hundreds of references
they began as you said increased
activity increased nurture this is why
this is like more exercise means higher
in my control so what people think about
the reasons why neurogenesis increases
with with exercise is because two things
one is its serotonin he takes this to
some extent insulin IGF ones involved in
it and they'd activity in hippocampus is
involved so we know several regulators
we don't know all the details but there
are endogenous mechanisms that are
affected by exercise which will we
should each affect neurogenesis and we
think that they're mediating it's not
it's not wrong to implicate mitochondria
I'm sure mitochondria are playing a role
in this as well still much work needs to
be done how do you relate the brain
plasticity when learning what okay how
do you relate the brain clusters
english-learning well you know if adult
neurogenesis is a form of playing plus
two C which it certainly is and we
believe that these cells are important
for learning information particularly
but as I said things that are closely
related to each other and my complete
are playing a pretty strong role
particularly we think there's there's
evidence that they're playing role in
making these new synapses bye-bye
gobbling up and thanks to tying the
existing synapses on the surface itself
so yeah Michael payroll what foods
slices I'm losing questions how much
time can elapse before synapse
rebuilding related to recovery happens
how much time can elapse before snaps
rebuilding recovery happens you know
that's going to be determined append on
the circumstances
looks like my time is up
you enjoyed this thanks very much bye